[Music]
with a travel hot plate
who needs room service just unpack this
single burner appliance and plug it into
an electrical outlet in the hotel room
it can be used to warm up soup fry eggs
or make espresso it's economical and
convenient no tips necessary a travel
hot plate offers another way to eat on
the road travelers can whip up something
to eat pretty much anywhere there is an
electrical outlet
production starts with steel wire for
the heating element the wire unwinds and
travels over rollers the rollers keep
the wire in an even tension as machinery
pulls it forward the machinery winds the
wire around a mandrel to produce a tight
coil a blade then chops the coil to the
correct length each coil will serve as a
heating element a worker slides the
coils ends onto hooks attached to a
fixture the fixture revolves and meets
up with an automated welder which fuses
the hook to the heating coil it welds
one hook to each end of the coil to
demonstrate the coils heating capacity a
technician connects it to an electrical
source and it very quickly becomes so
hot it glows a worker is now ready to
install the coil in the cast iron burner
[Music]
robots pick up the burners using
magnetic power and transfer them to a
conveyor system the conveyor pushes the
burners forward in the meantime a worker
threads the coil between posts in an
applicator head this puts the coil in
the correct configuration an automated
system then moves the applicator head
forward on the production line a
vibrating device applies sixteen and a
half tons of pressure to pack an
insulating compound into the cast iron
burners this compound is made of talcum
magnesite water and other ingredients
the applicator head embeds the heating
coil within the insulation allowing the
hooks to protrude this isolates the coil
from the cast iron burner to prevent
short circuits a worker coats each
burner with the rustproofing varnish
their burners bake at a temperature of
212 degrees Fahrenheit for 12 hours this
dries the varnish and hardens the
insulation in the burners out of the
oven a worker welds wires to the
protruding hooks which will connect to a
thermostat later she attaches ceramic
sleeves to the wires for electrical
insulation
she then spot-welds metal connectors to
the ends of the wires she installs an
intermediate backplate through which the
insulated connectors protrude and screws
the backplate in place another worker
installs a cover plate with numerous
holes to vent heat from the burner she
screws a threaded bolt into the hot
plate and attaches a ground wire to the
center screw she slides the thermostat
onto the threaded bolt and secures the
ground wire she adjusts the position of
the thermostat and connects the wires
she now attaches a plastic base and
screws a temperature knob into it she
joins the wires to a power cord and
stabilizes the connection with the
plastic clamp and cover she installs a
metal plate over the exposed wires to
encase them within the base structure
she slides rubber feet onto the nubs in
the plastic base and applies a label
with all the technical details
[Music]
using a probe she confirms that the hot
plate is functional that there is no
current leakage and the wiring is
properly isolated from the cast iron
burner a technician brings water to a
boil on a randomly selected hot plate
and measures the temperature to confirm
it heats water consistently he also aims
an infrared camera at the hot burner the
image proves that heat is evenly
disseminated across the surface once it
passes all these tests this travel hot
plate is ready to hit the road it should
provide the means to cook food wherever
in the world it happens to land
[Music]